تتعمق الفجوه في ايران كل ما صدخت اصوات
المعارضه في الشوارع
لكنها اصوات باتت من اقرب المقربين للنظام
ومن ابنائه واحفاده وعارضون بخلفيات
سياسيه او علاقات مباشره براس السلطه
بدات معارضه النظام الايراني من راس الهرم
خميني المرشد الاعلى السابق ومؤسس ما يسمى
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
قبض عليه في الثمانينات لوصفه نظام الحكم
في ايران بانه ديكتاتوريه رجال الدين
معارضه كلفته الممنعه من ترشحه للانتخابات
النيابيه عام 2008
فريده مراد خالي ابنه شقيقه المرشد
الايراني علي الخامنئي دفع الثمن دعوتها
الحكومات الاجنبيه الى قطع جميع علاقاتها
مع الحكومه الايرانيه اعتقالها بموجب امر
قضائي
حان الوقت لتقوم جميع البلدان الحره بحركه
رمزيه عن طريق استدعاء جميع ممثليها من
ايران وترضي كل منتسب لهذا النظام الوحشي
كطريقه للتعبير عن التضامن مع الشعب
الايراني الساعي لنيل الحريه
سلسله الاعتقالات التي يقدم عليها نظام
الايراني ضد كل ما يعارضه شامله ايضا
شخصيات ذات علاقه مباشره مع مسؤولين
السابقين احد تلك الامثله فائزه هاشم رصا
جونيا لابنه الثانيه للرئيس الايراني
الاسبق علي اكبر هاشم رفا سنجر المعروفه
بطفله الثوره الزوج بها في السجن
الرسميه الايرانيه